vladimir duthiers and we are in the CBS
this morning Toyota greenroom with New
York Times Book Review staff editor
Lauren Christensen welcome thanks for
having me she is here to share with us
some of her top summer reading
recommendations I've got him right here
so Lauren it's summer people want to
hang out the beach they want to you know
forget about all the trouble was about
all the things that they're reading in
the news and they want a good read so
let's start with some fiction books okay
first one and it's great that the title
of this book is just perfect my year of
rest and relaxation may be a bit
misleading I don't cover the cover art
is very great I mean there's some irony
and the title is probably not to be
surprising but Essen Mossberg she's the
author of Ilene of a couple years ago he
also wrote a story collection called
homesick for another world this is so
this is her newest book my year of rest
and relaxation it's a funny but darkly
funny look at you know female depression
and this woman who she's young it's the
year 2000 she you know she graduated
from a top university and she's living
in New York and she wants to sort of
numb herself to the difficulties that
she's faced in her life you know however
you want to describe these difficulties
she has lived a life of privilege she's
image conscious and so you know whether
or not she's really sympathetic is up to
the reader to decide but it's a
wonderful portrait that that has sort of
a a long lineage going back to even you
know Sylvia Plath you know looks like
looking at you know the the history of
female sort of neurotic disordered
thinking and psychological discomfort
it's it's a really it's a it's a
wonderful book so in this age where you
know we men are trying to understand
better the difficulties the challenges
that some women have in this day and age
is this a good book for guys to read to
get a little insight into the female
psyche absolutely right thank you Brian
over here ride it out absolutely and
why well it's it's it's it's dark and
it's very intense and you know Oh
Tessa's descriptions of sort of the
female psyche can can cut really deep I
will say though
she has a psychopharmacologist who's
prescribing her a lot of these sleep
medications and dr. Tuttle is her name
she is one of the funniest fictional
characters I have read in years
hilarious and I think a lot of people
will recognize sort of the satire and
sort of our over prescript prescribed
society so many and men and women will
relate okay cool so I'm putting this one
on this side here all right so next on
the list convenience store woman yes so
I picked this one as just a sort of
personal favorite I just took my first
trip to Japan and and have been
absolutely obsessed with Japanese
culture ever since a for people who
watch me on CBS this morning
I am a huge Japan well then you will
love this it's by Sayaka Murata
it's she's a very well-known novelist in
Japan but this is her first book that's
been translated into English so sort of
bringing her over to the Western world
it's the the prose is as sort of crisp
as is the sort of whole aesthetic of the
country that I found in the architecture
in the food and and I it just reminded
evoked everything I felt when I was in
the country but what's interesting so
it's about a young woman who works at a
convenience store and she works there
for I think about 20 years and she you
know she pours her life into this
convenience store and it becomes so much
part of her identity and she doesn't
have any aspirations beyond it she
doesn't want to get married she doesn't
want to you have a career beyond just
shelving and and things like that and I
think what's so interesting is that
Japanese culture is so much about
expectations and propriety and you know
the order of things and everyone in this
woman's life is saying why don't you
want to make more of yourself well how
can you be happy and she's sort of
saying well why does my happiness
threaten everyone else you know why
can't I just live according to what
makes me happy and I think that's such a
universal concept because a lot of
people struggle to understand the
fascination with Japanese culture I was
just talking to a colleague just this
week about the fact that everything is
orderly that reserved
you know when it says on the subway you
know don't use your phone people don't
you know where's here in this country
we're more individualistic and we'll
take umbrage to people telling us what
to do yeah and in Japan it's not so so I
wonder was this book first written in
Japanese yes so that's gonna be
interesting I think yes it was
translated yeah absolutely and I think
what's so interesting is you know she
does live a life that's pretty reserved
and secluded but other people are
imposing their expectations aren't to
her and she's sort of saying can you
just let me be and I just it really like
Lauren like okay I'm putting that one to
the side - okay let's go to war light so
much more well known author Michael che
he was the author of that book Oscar
winning movie etc well his newest book
called war light is set in London
immediately following World War two and
it's about a young family two teenage
kids whose parents have to leave them
behind in London to go the father gets a
job opportunity in Singapore so they
leave them behind in the care of these
you know met two men a very suspicious
intent and background there's you know
all kinds of adventure that I will not
give away but involving sort of
kidnapping plots and things like that I
wouldn't call it a thriller but you're
definitely in suspense okay and it's his
typical sort of moody atmospheric you
know you're unsure of yourself but what
the pace isn't so like so heart racing
but it definitely keeps you going but
and then meantime you find out that the
mother actually never went to Singapore
and she's become involved in sort of
some post-war intelligence work lot
twists yes absolutely I leave it there
but it's you know hit watch it is - yeah
it's not I wouldn't call it a beach read
but it's definitely you know a literary
exciting okay yeah so well I you know
the English Patient was it took me a
long time to get through it
this doesn't look at historical fiction
this that's why because I do huge
historical fiction putting it over here
alright moving on to give me your hand
by Megan out of it this is the one that
has not yet come it will be on sale next
week
it is the latest thriller from Megan
Abbott if you are into you know girl on
the train all kinds of psychological
fiction thrillers this is this is the
pick girl in the Train
really yeah I mean it's it's a twisted
portrait of female friendship two young
girls meet in a chemistry class in high
school and become extremely and you know
and wrapped in need to have each other's
lives but they're also intensely
competitive fast forward 20 years later
the narrator is working in a lab
studying a very rare but very dangerous
hormonal disorder that only affects
women okay she's working in a scientific
like chemistry lab and in walks her
friend from years ago who has shared
with her a very dark secret that you
only learn at the very end yeah yeah all
right yeah these are like I mean I'm
usually very picky about these books but
you're really selling them okay yes
nonfiction yes versatile award is a very
well-known Instagram poet right yes sort
of a new phenomenon that's really taking
the literary world as well so she has
written her first memoir and it's called
the terrible and it's written so much of
it there is prose but there's a lot of
sort of poetry as well and I think
that's such an interesting way to tell
your own life story it's it starts sort
of in North North England where she was
raised and goes through her life as a
model so she yeah because she she's like
half Jamaican half a jury exactly I was
based in Nigeria for many years and yeah
she was known there does she talk a
little bit about she does history or as
a way to understand sort of her
insecurities as a child with her image
consciousness and I'm trying to navigate
you know this this world in which she
looks so different from everyone else in
ways that are positive and negative I
mean she's she's absolutely stunning
she's very insecure about sort of her
role in life and you know it leads to
drugs and alcohol and and in her
modeling career and but you know it's an
ultimately uplifting ending I just think
it's it's a literally poetic look at
well I think it's it's interesting too I
think for a lot of people like myself
growing up multi
so you struggle to understand people
somebody today recently asked me if I
speak Thai and I'm like because I look
like I'm Thai like there's there are
people have been accusing me of being
different cultures my entire life
they've asked me if I'm Algerian if I
speak Arabic if I speak Spanish no right
but when you grow up in a world where
people try to box you into a certain
category it can be sort of debilitating
as a young person absolutely especially
when you're a model in your home I'm not
starting it's built on people staring at
you and and using you as just this
indicator of to sell things or things so
it's alright I'm putting that over here
- all right David Sedaris who can you
can never go wrong exactly so you know
very well-known essayist humorist his
latest book Calypso yeah you may have
read me talk pretty one day or less
explora diabetes with owls he's sort of
in later midlife I would say he's now in
his 60s and it's basically it's it's
really all about it most of it is set in
this beach house he buys with his
partner in North Carolina he gathers his
whole family together of sort of oddball
cast including but you know aside from
the humor all along with the humor I
love the cover I know the cover I know
mixed in with the humor is you know a
really sobering portrait of a man who
has lost his mother she and she was an
alcoholic and sort of grappling with
that as well as his sister to suicide
and there's a really poignant moment of
the love the last moment that he saw her
that you can tell he really deeply
regrets how he behaved towards her and
it's it's you know it's attacked head-on
but you can still tell that Sedaris
hasn't fully reconciled with it as no
one should be able to but you know it's
still it's so honest and it's humor and
it's sobriety and there's a particularly
hysterical moment where he's actually
feeding a tumor that has been removed
from his body a benign tumor to a turtle
on a beach and that's all I'm gonna say
it's you so there's really entire what
do you think our stage they're hyper
all right cool you can't go wrong with
Sedaris this is one I'm also really
intrigued by yeah how to change your
mind right so Michael Pollan author of
food rules and Omnivore's Dilemma very
you know celebrated food writer has
taken a slight turn toward you know from
food and diet to psychedelic so and he
actually and he you know I think he's a
self-described in this book square he'd
never done any drugs before he was not
sort of in the Ken Kesey generation or
he was but he didn't take part he has
dropped acid for the first time done
done several kinds of psychedelics and
rites so convincingly that you might
read this and want to drop acid or that
you understand it better and you see it
be a maybe but you see it beyond I mean
but you see it beyond the stigmas that
we have attached what is the Sigma with
dropping acid ivied everybody if you
know I don't think I mean like I I mean
that it was in the 60s it was sort of
considered like not a thing to do but I
think people as they started to
understand that there were some you may
medical benefits and they was used by
psychiatrists right so right so I mean
and the other thing is that micro dosing
has become sort of in vogue recently
with il Waldman's a really good day is a
book that came out I think a year or two
ago about taking micro doses of LSD to
treat very common psychological
disorders like instead of antidepressant
this is very different this is not micro
dosing this is macro dosing this is
taking enough quantities of the drugs to
actually feel the effects and trip and
is it just a description of what happens
to you once you take the second like The
Omnivore's Dilemma I mean there's well
it's a there's guidance in those but
there is guidance there's also a lot of
history there's social history it's it's
a phenomenon that goes way back he
starts he starts with the 1930s when it
was first sort of accidentally
discovered from fungus you know the
mushrooms thing and you know it takes
you along so even if you would never
touch a drug in your life this book it's
it's also how mushrooms are drug
stay tuned no I mean I think what's so
interesting is that I think the title
says so much more whether you are
interested in psychedelics or not it's a
portrait of a man who's changing his
mind it's it's uprooting our very
deep-seated associations and
expectations and judgments and saying
well what if I what if I step outside my
comfort zone for a second look at what
could happen and he also says that
psychedelics I mean one of the
assumptions is that it's very bad for
you or addictive he says it's not even
as bad for you as like died dr. pepper
right I mean it all right yeah I'm not a
doctor yes but you know heard him saying
it's a very it's a really convincing and
well-written well so books are my drug
so I I think that I'm going to like a
book like this is for people who want to
step out of their comfort zone and
perhaps have their attitudes changed
about drugs and about psychedelics in
general because you may come to a book
like this with some very like sort of
narrow views a very authoritative man
who's changed too so he doesn't say at
the end that you should oh I don't think
he's legally allowed there is a
disclaimer in the beginning yeah this
only happened to me right yeah this at
home all right so this is an incredible
this is just an enormous amount of like
really quality books that you've bought
from here and I feel like I need to read
all of them and so I'm going to keep
them I'm looking at Jackie our books
producer we can book club them whenever
you're done yes how many book clubs are
you I'm not in any book club my job is a
book I know but still like you wouldn't
Pete your friends like I don't think
they want me in the book club is the
real thing yeah like an email book club
I'll send you the books that I'm reading
and you're saying you don't cover
graphic friends like you know Duke I
don't do comic books glad thank you so
much for stopping yeah so if you want to
learn more about these books there's
nothing on the prompter so I don't know
if I'm supposed to be saying anything
else but it's been if we just say
bye-bye everyone in the room was like
just say bye bye say bye bye love bye
bye thank you thank you